guías de consultas la oposición
mayoritaria de venezuela finalmente puso
sobre la mesa su propuesta para lograr
una transición en el país el denominado
pacto unitario fue presentado por el
líder opositor juan guaidó firmado por
37 organizaciones políticas acuerda
rechazar las próximas elecciones
parlamentarias
y
una manera nacional en ganar
el texto insiste también en la necesidad
de sentar las bases de un gobierno de
emergencia nacional y de escalar la
presión internacional sólo un camino que
conjugue la presión internacional y la
presión interna podrá conducir a la
liberación de venezuela sin embargo
todavía se desconoce qué estrategias
utilizarán los firmantes para llevar a
cabo el plan varias de las propuestas no
profundizan en detalles esperados por
actores políticos ellos notan también
que weldon nunca ha logrado cuestionar a
los otros tres grupos opositores y que
nuevamente se refiere a las mismas
organizaciones políticas que ya se sabía
que rechazaba en el proceso electoral
del 6 de diciembre dirigentes
tradicionales de la oposición venezolana
como el dos veces candidato presidencial
henrique capriles han rechazado
públicamente la ruta que ha marcado way
de capriles considera que es un desatino
abstenerse de participar en las
elecciones ya que las considera una
oportunidad para enfrentarse al gobierno
why does sin embargo aclaró que no era
un pacto cerrado
expresamente a la fuerza armada nacional
a sumarse